we got this clip here Jack besobic what
the funk has anyone seen water do this
so let's let's start this clip over and
we'll play it they're talking this is
East Palestine Ohio
whoa wait whoa wow
that doesn't oh whoa it's all in the
bottom of the creek bed yeah that's
that's what oil does right yeah yeah so
when the rock hits the water it knocks
all the chemicals up to the surface it's
on the bottom the difference is on top
of the water yeah it's that vinyl so
it's heavier well it could be a it's a
group they had a group of chemicals
these trains there's three of them main
ones there's Vinyl chloride there's
something called butyl acrylate and
there's another stuff thing called
Benzene which is extremely dangerous to
burn they said that the Benzene was only
a residual Benzene but this is like
they're not going to tell you if there's
a ton of benzene that got burned it
creates dioxin which is a persistent uh
toxin it's the only one of those that's
persistent it's the dioxin so really the
the vinyl chloride is a half like it's
like 2.3 days there was something about
how the vinyl chloride was created
hydrochloric acid I've heard that if it
mixes with water it can create yeah acid
but apparently the vinyl chloride the
butyl acrylate are not that big of a
deal after you know two or three weeks
they start to work their way out of the
environment
it turns out it was good that they
burned those things because otherwise as
they go up and they come back down and
coat every coat stuff so that stuff was
released but it's the Benzene and we
need to know more about how much Benzene
was on those trains they just tell us it
was Benzene residue and that maybe from
previous shipments or maybe there's a
little bit but I've got a feeling I
wouldn't be surprised if the official
reports are not true like where is Joe
Biden right now well they don't want to
admit that you know a small town mayor
that was only hired for one single
reason you know isn't doing a good job
oh the the Secretary of Transportation
booty judge yeah yeah so and there's
reports I talked to my mom who lives in
Ohio they're near Akron Ohio so they're
about 70 miles west of this that the
federal government offered assistance in
the governor of Ohio declined said they
didn't want help uh I don't know if it's
true this is just what I was told by one
of my parents Mike dewine Mike dewine
the Governor Mike dewine had a presser
yesterday and he was saying that uh what
was it Norfolk Southern said that they
would pay for everything I thought they
were offering people like a thousand
bucks to shut up there I don't know I
didn't hear that I know that they were
offering there was the town hall that
they had last night they were offering
people to move to like pay for them to
move what does that mean buying your
house I guess I don't really understand
well you do not want to be breathing in
dioxins like those that is uh yeah I
mean there's something like less than 5
000 people in that town
um right now or before total like it's a
Tiny Town I think but it's not even
about that yeah it's about the
Mississippi it's about the whole region
about the Ohio River Basin where West
Virginia the majority of West Virginia
is going to get into this yeah yeah
we're lucky we're not we're like in this
you're over from what I've been here
forever right so you guys won't have to
deal with the water I I think we're not
connected to it oh okay I mean they're
all connected in some fashion but like
it doesn't flow in to us because I know
that even the charts show where I'm at
in Atlanta like North Georgia north of
me is affected but wow yeah there's a
there's a Twitter account called General
underscore jwj just retweet whatever it
is I did actually I retweeted it last
night uh the character name is lanius on
it and it's a long thread and he breaks
down he or she breaks down basically
things I've been talking about the three
different chemicals involved the
half-life of the different chemicals and
it seems too suggests that
um where I saw the map I saw the map on
your feed and I don't know if that map I
mean that's just the map that's the Ohio
river and it's like if it gets
contaminated that area could be
destroyed or or I liked your response to
the government yeah the government says
not accurately potentially contempted
drinking water and you put this is
unconfirmed by official or government
sources don't wait for confirmation yeah
this is take care of yourself first and
then if they're not going to come tell
you if you're about to die like you know
no they don't want to create Panic what
was the account you retweeted that's
called lanius l-a-n-i-u-s uh it's from
last night so it'd be yes it is this is
a pretty cool thread everyone if you get
a chance check it out it's got a lot of
data I don't know I have not been able
to confirm or deny the accuracy of it
but it's pretty um thorough and the he
kind of Intimates that the water is not
at a danger it's not really the water
it's the surrounding air well and that's
where this DC and everything it's all
upwind of that so it's all everything's
going to move East so just like it
should be affected yeah yeah
but you can't shoot these out of the sky
and I also think it would they're not
too concerned about I don't know I don't
know that it wasn't too concerned about
it going far away from the source that
it's just like a local heavy uh
pollutant but then it's like if there's
a lot of dioxin in the air it's a
different story that stuff doesn't go
away and I know people that live in that
see that area has been brutalized by
lung and health issues for a long time
because it's still City and it's cool
cold area so they have had these types
of health issues and now they're going
to have just another one added onto it
yep
this is why they ship jobs to China by
the way this is big it literally is
economic but this is one of the main
ones because if there's a spill they
want it over there that that that's a
huge reason why Trump was removing
environmental regulations uh and
protections the idea is that we don't
want these toxic chemicals and
pollutants in our air so make China do
it where they're smog filled and
polluted to crap and then we have clean
skies and use the Petro dollar to
maintain our economy Trump wanted to
bring the factories back so he said in
order to do so you got to lower their
taxes and you've got to reduce the
regulations on them and people like no
because then we'll see more ecological
disasters like this and they're right
but the upside is we control our own
production line we have our own steel we
have our own mining we got a buy it all
from China if we go to war with China we
lose our product we lose I mean you lose
if you go to war with your trade Ally
and they're shipping you your steel you
lose the war yeah that's actually a huge
problem also we lose the Innovation that
comes with having Manufacturing in your
country when you have the all of the
factories you're innovating processes
just like we did we
um you know Ford created the assem
assembly line like Ford or don't like
Ford he created the assembly line we're
not doing any kinds of innovation like
that at this point because we're not
doing any of the manufacturing I'd like
to see drone Manufacturing in space
because like when you have low gravity
you can have 100 million drones all
working in Synergy on a machine moving
pieces of metal together and so size is
almost Irrelevant in construction you
can just be space force should get on
that dude this is a huge space Fleet
that'd be awesome this image is is
really important to understand what's
going on what the dangers are
bioaccumulation so a contaminant gets in
the soil or the dirt or whatever the
plants absorb some of it as they grow
the insects will eat those plants the
birds will eat the insects and then
eventually at the higher level the food
that we eat will be heavily contaminated
with these chemicals I don't know
specifically about the ones in Ohio
though that's part of why bottom feeding
fish like shrimp and or they're not fish
but bottom feeding sea creatures are
they say you know high in lead high in
metals is because of the bio Mercury
shrimp shrimp or bottom feeders although
yeah shrimp or bottom feeders lobsters
new Lobster was I muscles clams things
like that aren't catfish Bottom Feeders
yeah that's why they tell you not to eat
Bottom Feeders because they're full of
garbage yeah the heavy metal falls down
they eat it uh or or they eat things
that have already eaten it Etc people
like it though catfish that's like a big
I mean yeah I think you've got a Cracker
Barrel yeah you catch any catfish with
hot dogs so I mean wait what yeah just
wait around pretty sure you just toss
like that's what you use as a bait drag
it across the ground they'll suck
they'll eat anything so wow oh wow all
right well I didn't know that anyway
we're downwind from This Disaster so uh
yeah how are you doing I bought a bunch
of air filters yesterday
um and I got up my water filtration
situation I got a bunch of Life straws
and a big daddy LifeStraw that's like
three gallon take it down to the river
fill it up uh obviously looking at Water
distillation because a few ways to get
vinyl act um what was it vinyl chloride
vinyl out of your water is distillation
boiling it's not enough I think boiling
it might help because it'll release the
gas a lot of it's just interesting but
um distillation's the key and something
also called uh air air there's a there's
an industrial method to get rid of vinyl
acrylate or vinyl uh chloride God these
names man I'm not a chemist monochloride
is uh it's like air air blowing or
something I was looking at the uh I was
looking at the collapse of the energy
Grid in South Africa and everything
that's going on there and I started
thinking uh I should buy a generator
yeah you should I just got one totally
gonna do that send me the information
because I don't know what to tell you
about it right now
I got a 1000 watt solar battery well
it's a 1000 watt battery jackery is the
company uh I mean we have all these
genres talking about solar batteries
yeah and I don't know if the Brand's
necessarily important but I it has
extremely good reviews John Rich was
talking about a two he has two of them
mine's a thousand watt and then two
solar panels okay yeah good reviews is
important because you don't know if it's
gonna work as well as this as it does
what do you do you just pop it outside
and yeah yeah I think within eight hours
you can get about a thousand watts of
power charged I mean uh you got your USB
ports your your plug I have no idea how
much wattage it takes to power a little
house though
yeah more than that little thing yeah
1800 watts maybe to 1000 watt battery
might get you about six to eight hours
of freezer a freezer for eight hours
yeah but I don't know all the exacts you
know what we got to do though is we got
to get away from electric based systems
for things we don't need so for instance
there's a couple of technological
revolutions heading our way one is this
one's easy uh black piping run across
your roof what's that heat water
literally black pipes okay on your roof
and the sun water it absorbs the
sunlight heats the water creating a
pressurized hot water system you know
it's a great day when you have a sand
filled blocks that build that you can
use to build at your house and if you
put those on the my aunt has this in
Connecticut and she has one wall that is
all sand and the Sun hits it and that
room gets so toasty warm in the dead of
winter and otherwise it's wood stoves in
her house but that room is the toastiest
warmestry the other thing the other
thing is we talked about this a few
years ago it's a I think it's a closed
system fluid that can absorb and release
infrared energy so the idea was you can
have it absorb sunlight but it doesn't
get hot itself you then run it in into
the house where you can then use another
process to trigger the release of the
energy and heat things up this is
passive solar is what this is like
there's like backpacking Backpackers use
all this type of stuff all the time like
the solar showers the solar the solar
chargers and everything like that I have
a couple of each of those things and you
just yeah you take them out there you
hang it up and you get passive solar and
triple glazed windows and you're all set
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time